[Music]
all right up next is joseph from little
rock arkansas hey joseph welcome to the
show
hi how are y'all we're doing great how
can we help
bottom line i um my finances are in good
shape i have a i'm 21 my wife's 24 we
have a six month old baby and basically
um
just just want to know how to plan for
the future i mean the world is crazy my
job i don't know how long the supply
would would keep up and we could hit a
hiccup in my job to where you know
can't get the materials you can't work
so
i'm just trying to figure out the best
way to prepare for that long term okay
so so you guys are debt free
uh do you guys have money saved in the
bank
uh yes how much do you have is it three
we recommend that three three to six
months of expenses
uh we have about 28 000 okay so what is
that what is that for you guys like if
if you're so say your job stopped
immediately how many months
would you guys have to that you'd be
okay
we can live on 1500 a month
okay and you have how much savings um
uh 28 000. oh wow you got plenty it's a
fully funded emergency fund for you guys
i mean you're looking at nine grand and
you've got 28.
yeah so you got plenty there so what are
you worried about
losing your job
no no not that
my dad's my dad has a bunch of rental
property
and you know that that's great but
there's also a lot of overhead in rental
property there's you know there's
management problems then there's also
you know there's just a lot of overhead
and he's big into rental property rental
property but right now you can't buy
rental property it's ridiculous so other
than that you know i just the best way
to plan
besides just rental property
so are you trying to plan for the future
are you planning for the apocalypse i
can't tell sure
um the future okay so if you're just
looking at the future you're 21 you got
your whole life ahead of you you got
this six month old are you just wanting
to invest to make sure that you're able
to retire when you want to
yes okay are you guys investing anything
right now
no we're not you're not okay so that's
the first thing i would do joseph is i
would press play
on
your investing strategy which would be
putting 15 percent of your household
income into retirement every year so
whether that's um you know roth ira is a
great option does your company offer a
401k
uh no it's a family business it's a
failing business okay so yeah so i would
just i would talk to a smart investor
pro and look to see okay here are my
options
um to put some money away and it could
be you know through a retirement
vehicles is ideal is that 15 and then
above that
if you guys still have margin you're
okay i want to i want to do something
then yeah above that is when you look at
um you know paying off your current
house if it's not paid off
and then also you know whether it's
investing in the market and good mutual
funds if it is buying a rental property
which could be you know four years down
the road because usually when you buy an
investment property the way
we go about it and i know for sure dave
it's it's that you make your money on
the sale so it would be a situation
where it's getting something yes where
you get a great deal and you pay cash
for it so joseph do you have a mortgage
no okay so you're renting right now
no we own it you own it oh you own it
free and clear how much do you guys make
a year yeah
um
the average week is around three to five
thousand but there's some weeks we're in
the roof in business so you know we
can't roof all year so there's some
business where we may go you know
several weeks without working at all
well you got no payments in the world
and uh you're making 60 grand invest 15
percent do the roth ira beyond that you
might look at a brokerage account but
dude you're going to build well if
you're 21. yeah relax breathe and he
wins the race you're doing great joseph
doing great